en este vídeo vamos a ver las tendencias
de la tabla periódica de los elementos
para dimensiones como la ionización de
energía radio atómico iónico afinidad
electrónica y electrón negatividad para
hacer esto vamos a comenzar con una idea
fundamental en química y física y es la
ley de colom y para nuestros propósitos
podemos ver que la ley de colom dice que
la magnitud de la fuerza entre dos
partículas cargadas va a ser
proporcional a la carga de la primera
partícula multiplicada por la carga de
la segunda partícula dividida entre el
cuadrado de la distancia entre estas dos
partículas cuando pensamos en esto en el
contexto de la tabla periódica y los
diferentes átomos podemos ver a q1 como
la carga positiva efectiva de los
protones en el núcleo de un átomo y a q2
como la carga de un electrón ahora
cualquier electrón va a tener la misma
carga negativa pero como tratamos de
comprender las tendencias en la tabla
periódica es realmente el nivel más
externo del átomo los electrones de
valencia el más interesante estos son
los que describen la reactividad por lo
cuando pensamos en la distancia entre
las dos cargas vamos a pensar en la
distancia entre el núcleo y aquellos
electrones de valencia en el nivel más
externo ahora podemos ver esta carga
efectiva que llamaremos se está efectiva
como que es igual a la diferencia entre
la carga en el núcleo podemos ver esto
como el número atómico o el número de
protones para cierto elemento o un átomo
de ese elemento la diferencia entre esto
y lo que se conoce como ese o que tantos
niveles hay existen modelos complicados
para esto pero para una clase
introductoria de química esto se
aproxima con el número de electrones
internos
recuerden que realmente queremos pensar
en lo que sucede con los electrones de
valencia
así que si imaginamos un núcleo aquí en
color anaranjado que tiene protones en
él y electrones internos digamos que
estos son los electrones internos en el
primer nivel energético y luego
electrones internos en el segundo nivel
y digamos que los electrones de valencia
están en el tercer nivel por lo que hay
electrones de valencia aquí están
borrosos están en estos orbitales eso
electrones de valencia que tienen una
carga negativa serán atraídos por la
carga positiva del núcleo pero también
serán rechazados por todos estos
electrones internos que se encuentran
entre ellos y es por eso que una
aproximación de la carga efectiva que
podrían experimentar estos electrones de
valencia será la carga del núcleo - y
esta es una aproximación la cantidad de
electrones internos que tienen entonces
si usamos eso más o menos como una forma
de pensar acerca de z efectiva cuáles
creen que serán las tendencias en la
tabla periódica cuál será la carga
efectiva para los elementos de este
grupo 1 bueno el hidrógeno no tiene
electrones internos y tiene un número
atómico de 1 así que 10 va a tener una
carga efectiva de aproximadamente 1 el
número atómico de litio es 3 - 2
electrones internos que están en 1s
entonces vamos a tener 3 menos 2 una
carga efectiva de 1 así que por lo
general todos los elementos del grupo 1
tienen una carga efectiva de 1 y qué
pasa con los halógenos cuál es
la carga efectiva aquí bien si vemos el
flúor con número atómico 9 tiene 2
electrones internos en el primer nivel
por lo que tiene una carga efectiva de 7
el cloro de hecho tiene una carga
efectiva de 7 por la misma razón su
número atómico es 17 pero tiene 10
electrones internos y si fuéramos más
hacia la derecha hacia los gases nobles
podemos ver que el helio va a tener una
carga efectiva de 2 el número atómico 2
- 0 electrones internos pero cuando
llegamos al neón tenemos el número
atómico de 10 y luego restamos los
electrones internos veremos que conforme
pasamos por los gases nobles que no sean
el helio tendrán una carga efectiva de 8
así que la tendencia general es que la
carga efectiva es menor a la izquierda
la carga efectiva es menor para el grupo
1 y entonces cuando vamos hacia la
derecha de la tabla periódica tenemos
una zeta efectiva que va a ser más alta
así que dentro de un periodo dado o
dentro de un renglón dado en la tabla
periódica los electrones externos o
electrones de valencia está
en el mismo nivel pero la carga efectiva
aumenta conforme vamos de izquierda a
derecha así que está con uno aquí va a
incrementar qué efecto va a tener esto
en el radio del átomo bueno la ley de
colom dirá que la magnitud de la fuerza
de atracción entre esas cargas opuestas
va a ser más grande así que aunque
agregamos electrones conforme pasamos de
izquierda a derecha dentro de un renglón
dentro de un periodo los átomos en
general van a ser más pequeños
permítanme escribirlo así conforme vamos
de izquierda a derecha por lo general el
radio disminuye ahora cuál es la
tendencia dentro de la columna bueno una
forma de pensar en esto es que conforme
bajamos en la columna conforme bajamos
en un grupo llenamos los niveles que
están más lejanos así que esperaríamos
que el radio aumentará conforme
descendemos en una columna o en un grupo
o podríamos decir que el radio disminuye
conforme subimos en el grupo así que el
radio disminuye cuáles son las
tendencias en la tabla periódica de los
elementos
no el radio va a disminuir conforme
subimos y conforme vamos a la derecha
así que podríamos dibujar una flecha más
o menos así y sin duda es el caso para
la mayoría de las mediciones que el
helio se considera el átomo más pequeño
un átomo neutro de helio y el francio se
considera el átomo más grande ahora
podemos usar esto para pensar en otras
tendencias de la tabla periódica que hay
por ejemplo de la energía de ionización
como recordatorio la primera energía de
ionización es la energía mínima
requerida para quitar el primer electrón
de una versión neutra de ese elemento y
ya que es la energía mínima va a tener
que ser uno de esos electrones externos
va a ser uno de los electrones de
valencia así que qué es lo que va a
generar eso bueno pueden imaginar que la
energía de ionización va a ser alta en
casos donde las fuerzas de colom son
altas y cuáles son las situaciones en
donde las fuerzas de colom son altas
bueno esta va a ser una situación en
donde tenemos una carga altamente
efectiva y donde tenemos un radio
pequeño un radio pequeño hace que la
fuerza de colom sea
y una carga efectiva hace que aumente la
fuerza de coloma tenemos el radio más
pequeño arriba a la derecha y tenemos la
carga más efectiva y alta a la derecha
así que podemos esperar que las energías
más altas de ionización ocurran en la
esquina superior derecha lo que tiene
sentido intuitivo estos gases nobles son
muy estables ellos no quieren liberar un
electrón se va a necesitar mucha energía
para quitar uno de esos electrones el
flúor y cloro están tan cercanos para
completar su nivel que lo último que
quieren es perder un electrón así que de
nuevo se requiere mucha energía para
quitar ese primer electrón por otra
parte tenemos algo como el francia este
tiene un electrón de valencia y es el
electrón de valencia está muy lejos de
su núcleo hay una baja carga efectiva a
pesar de todos los protones porque hay
muchos niveles energéticos en los
electrones internos por lo que no nos
sorprende que no se requiere demasiada
energía para quitar ese primer electrón
del francio ahora otra tendencia en la
que podemos pensar que de cierta forma
es lo opuesto es la afinidad de
electrones
la energía de ionización se refiere a la
energía necesaria para quitar un
electrón mientras que la afinidad de
electrónica trata de cuánta energía se
liberará si agregamos un electrón a la
versión neutra de un elemento dado así
que la alta afinidad electrónica tiene
que ver con aquellos que realmente
quieren un electrón así que ellos deben
tener una alta fuerza de columbia entre
su núcleo y los electrones más externos
lo que significa que deben tener una
alta z efectiva y eso también quiere
decir que deben de tener un re bajo una
forma de pensar en esto es que vamos a
tener una tendencia similar con la
diferencia de que los gases nobles no
quieren ganar o perder electrones pero
sabemos que los francios y los claros
del mundo pueden volverse más estables y
ganan un electrón en realidad ellos
pueden liberar energía por lo que
tendríamos una alta afinidad electrónica
para la esquina superior derecha
especialmente los halógenos y tenemos
baja afinidad electrónica en la parte
inferior izquierda ahora hay una pequeña
peculiaridad en las convenciones
químicas generalmente se dice que el
flúor y el cloro
y los elementos arriba a la derecha que
son gases nobles tienen una mayor
afinidad electrónica y es el caso de que
se libera energía cuando agregamos un
electrón a una versión neutra de ellos
sucede con esa convención y esto puede
ser algo confuso que cuando liberamos
energía tenemos afinidad electrónica
negativa pero generalmente cuando
decimos que hay una alta afinidad
electrónica
este elemento va a liberar más energía
cuando puede obtener un electrón ahora
una noción que está relacionada con la
afinidad electrónica es la electro
negatividad y la diferencia entre las
dos puede ser a veces algo confusa la
electro negatividad trata de cuando un
átomo comparte un par de electrones con
otro átomo que tan probable es que los
atraiga hacia sí mismo en comparación
con la atracción que ejerce sobre ellos
el otro átomo pueden imaginar que se
correlaciona fuertemente con la afinidad
electrónica los elementos que liberan
energía cuando pueden ser ionizados para
obtener un electrón si ellos forman un
enlace y están compartiendo un par de
electrones es más probable que acaparen
esos electrones la afinidad de
electrónica
es fácil de medir podemos verla cuando
este elemento está en estado gaseoso y
si agregamos electrones veremos cuánta
energía se libera normalmente se mide en
kilos por mol del átomo en cuestión
mientras que la electro negatividad no
es tan clara en su medición pero puede
ser un concepto útil en futuros vídeos
si pensamos en diferentes átomos que
comparten pares de electrones y donde
pasan la mayor parte del tiempo esos
electrones así que lo dejamos aquí por
hoy comenzamos con la fuerza de coulomb
y pudimos intuir un montón de tendencias
pensando solamente en la ley de coulomb
y la tabla periódica de los elementos